- [Narrator] In this curious
lagoon, the rivers may run red,
but rest assured, it's water, not blood.
Although you could be forgiven
for confusing the two.
The red lagoon is located
12,000 feet above sea level,
in an area of Chile so remote,
that it wasn't even known by
the National Tourism Office
until 2009.
And maybe that's a good thing,
because much like the pyramids in Egypt,
the lagoon is believed to be cursed.
Legend says that the waters
are owned by the devil himself,
and he is responsible for
the mysterious disappearances
that have occurred along the shores.
The thermal temperatures of the water,
at 100 to 120 degrees,
stop even wild animals
from approaching it.
Devils aside, what causes
this blood-red water?
Well, biologists studying
the lagoon recently traced it
to algae growing in
the depths of the lake.
Still, much of this
lagoon remains a mystery.
A visit to this place is a
reminder that there's still
much to marvel at on this planet.